Please welcome the Executive Culinary Director,
and host of the cooking show on VICE, best channel.
It's Farideh Sadeghin!
(crowd clapping)
Yay!
It's so nice to be back here with you.
Farideh,
I basically did not play it cool.
I was like, when's our next date?
(Farideh giggling)
You know what, I like to book early, so this is awesome.
Let's do this.
Wait, have you ever had this before, by the way?
I've only ever seen it and I've never had it.
And if your crunch wrap told me anything,
you're gonna have to pry this out of my hand.
All right, all right. Well, this is good.
So essentially it's like a bag of corn chips,
that you're filling up with chili.
In the Midwest with the walking taco,
it's more so like
ground beef at season's kind of like tacos.
So that's what we're doing right now.
We're building our chili.
So we've got our onions and garlic going,
and we're gonna add ground cumin, paprika,
chili powder, oregano, and some salt right on in there.
Look how beautiful that is.
I mean, it really is. And it smells amazing.
All right, so we're just gonna dump
that right in there.
Dump that in there,
and it's just gonna like,
flood the whole studio and your kitchen at home.
This is the most fragrant dish.
Also, just in general, I think that
like the smell of onion and garlic just together.
When I was a kid,
we're gonna add the tomato paste, by the way.
When I was a kid, my dad would be cooking dinner,
and we would smell the onion and the garlic.
And you're just like, what is that odor?
And it's just, you're like, this is like
make that, and like your whole family will love you.
It's pretty good.
So we get the walking taco also.
I think that like, like any good thing
in the U.S, it was invented essentially
at like a county fair though.
The world's fair type thing, right?
All of those good things.
And I think this was at like the 1982,
one is what I've heard.
I used to go to this one called Pomona fair,
outside of Los Angeles.
And I remember hearing for the first time
I bought like a fried avocado.
And I was like, "I want one."
That's very California.
Of course, they're gonna have
Very California.
fried avocado there.
So the tomato paste has gone in yet.
And I always like just cooked the tomato paste
a couple of minutes just to get that, like
get it kind of caramelized a little bit.
And yeah, the ground beef right on in there.
Now, I think that like a lot
of people have their own chili recipe.
And if you have your own chili recipe that you love,
like use that.
I mean, I think that some people don't put beans in there,
so we're putting beans in ours right now.
Exactly.
You know, like Texas style chili,
like a hundred percent,
there's no beans in that.
I want a bean in my chili.
Yeah. Yeah.
Throw the beans in.
We're gonna throw beans in.
We're gonna throw in tomatoes, pureed tomatoes.
We're gonna do some beef broth as well.
And don't forget, we're gonna also add some beer in here,
whatever beer you kinda like.
I like, you know, maybe a lighter one.
You can add the whole one, or keep some out and
have the rest-
Enjoy.
for yourself, also.
And Farideh, do you reduce the liquid?
You're gonna reduce, so this is gonna cook
for like an hour and a half, two hours.
Whatever, it's just gonna build so much flavor.
And don't forget, most of these kinds of stews,
always tastes better the next day.
And the longer you cook them,
the more kind of compounded those flavors are gonna be,
and it's just gonna be even better.
So be patient.
My favorite pork tacos,
I won't even serve them
until they've been in the fridge overnight.
Yeah, exactly.
And you're gonna stew like that.
This is gonna sit here. It's gonna cook.
I mean, everyone's gonna end up
eating those later and they're gonna be so happy.
But we're gonna build some walking tacos now.
So, yeah, we've got our little bag of chips.
And I think that like, you know, part of this is,
is that like the joy of being able to top it
with anything you want.
You know?
I mean, how do you top your chili normally?
Well, also I love like a baked potato bar.
So like doing fix-ins and fill-ins is just
kinda like,
Oh, yeah.
I would say it's my kind of bag.
But I think that would be a little pun intended.
(Farideh laughing)
I'm gonna throw on some sour cream.
We're gonna do some shredded cheddar.
Yeah, some white onion if you'd like,
I love raw onions.
Me too, right?
I'm a big raw onion fan.
I love a little cilantro.
Yes.
I'm gonna freshen it up with some lime.
Yeah. This is gonna be delicious.
(Drew breaths out)
Squirting everywhere, there you go.
Okay. Oh my gosh.
I don't know whether to use a fork or a spoon.
I'm going spoon.
Me too.
Oh, Yeah.
I mean, you're gonna have the crunch
of the, you know,
corn chips in there.
I'm making sure to kind of get every element
in my bite too.
I'm getting mainly sour cream,
cause it's my favorite part.
(tacos crunching)
Oh my god.
(Farideh laughing)
We did it again.
Farideh.
(Farideh laughing)
Not too bad, right?
This is so incredible, thank you.
I've always wanted to try the walking taco,
and I've never had the privilege
and I see what all the fuss is about.
It's amazing.
Walk around and eat it, you know?
Farideh, what's next?
What are we gonna do next?
That like, we can empower to cook at home.
Oh my gosh.
We have so many things.
Okay, I almost feel like we should stick with this,
like world's fair stuff.
And maybe we'll do like funnel cakes or something.
Sure.
You know?
Fried avocados.
Fried avocados, why not?
You know what I've never done at home?
And it's one of my favorite foods also, is a corn dog.
Oh, a corn dog? Yes!
I love a corn dog.
Hell yeah.
And you can make them with vegan dogs too.
Yeah, you can.
I mean, and also this can be done with,
I mean you could make a vegetarian chili.
Absolutely.
Any kind of thing you wanted with this.
Like this is the world is your oyster,
and kind of go with it.
All right, we're gonna figure out our next recipe.
And thank you, Farideh.
Go to the drewbarrymoreshow.com for the full recipe.
(upbeat music)